ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES BELL
FORGES BRADFORD CABALLERO
CHIANG DALLY DODD THEY'RE ALSO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ ROOF
HERTZBERG HELLO WHAT'S SO- TADO
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MONNING MORLOCK MORALE
NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO RALPH
RUBIO SKINNER AND STERN I'M
BURKE WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE
WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN
SISTER MAHDIA COMBOS AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. BY
SENATOR STEVE GLAZER. GUIDE
MAKE THIS YOUR SALT FOR THE
EARTH. THAT IN OUR HUMBLE
HIDDEN ACTS OF GENEROSITY IN
PEACE. WE MAYREVEAL YOUR LOVE
IN THE MIDST OF A SONG. MAKERS
YOUR LIGHT FOR THE WORLD THAT
WE MAY REFLECT YOUR COMPASSION
AND FORGIVENESS. THE LIGHT AND
WARMTH OF YOUR LOVE IN THE
MIDST OF A COLD WINTER. MAKE US
YOUR CITY ON THE HILL. THE
VISION OF YOUR DREAM OF A WORLD
UNITED IN YOUR JUSTICE AND
MERCY. WE ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME
AMEN. MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE TO OUR
FLAG I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE.
AND WHICH STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE.
MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. PRO TEM ATKINS YEAH.
SORRY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO RECOGNIZE
SEVEN OUTSTANDING CALIFORNIANS
BEING HONORED BY THE JAMES
IRVINE FOUNDATION FOR THEIR
INNOVATIVE AND EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS THE PRESSING ISSUES
FACING OUR STATE. THE ISSUES
INCLUDE CAREER READINESS CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT PAROLE PROCESS
REFORM ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
FINANCIAL ACCESS FOR YOUTH AND
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT THE
FOUNDATION RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF
NOMINATIONS FOR THIS TREMENDOUS
HONOR AND THEY SELECTED SEVEN
LEADERS FROM SIX ORGANIZATIONS.
THESE INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUALS
ARE IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR STATE
THERE IS NO VADER TACKLE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES CREE NATION.
THEIR SHINING A LIGHT ON
PROMISING NEW WAYS TO UPLIFT
PLEASE PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR VULNERABLE RESIDENTS AND
PREPARE OUR STATE FOR
PROSPEROUS SUSTAINABLE FUTURE.
THEY FIT OUT WHAT WORK AND
WHERE I NEEDED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY HONOR THEM LEARN.
GRADUATION TO THE YOUR BOARD OF.
IF THE INS FOR YOUR EX. WORK I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE THE HONOR
OF PRESENTING EACH RECIPIENT
WITH THEIR A WARD AND I WOULD
SAY WELL. I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
YOU BUT I'VE SEEN THE FACES OF
MY COLLEAGUES AS WE HEAR THEIR
STORIES EACH YEAR THAT WE DO
THIS. IT IS REALLY AN HONOR AS
THE PROTECT HIM OF THE SENATE
WITH MY SENATE COLLEAGUES TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS TODAY SO. I
WILL TURN IT OVER YOU ARE I'M
REALLY THE FIRST- SENATOR
FURTADO FOR THE FIRST
PRESENTATION. SENATOR HER
TAUGHT AT. SENATOR HERTZBERG
DESK. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM.
OUR FIRST RECOGNITION GOES TO
VERONICA GUIDED BY IN PHOEBE
SETON FOR THEIR WORK BUILDING
COMMUNITY STRENGTH IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN COACHELLA VALLEY'S
ADVOCACY AND LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT. ON A TEN PHOEBE
KNOW THAT TOO MANY WORKING
FAMILIES ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY AT COACHELLA
VALLEY STRUGGLE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET AND MANY LACK THE BASIC
HUMAN RIGHTS SUCH AS SAFE
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER CLEAN
AIR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
RELIABLE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
THEY ALSO KNOW LIKE I DO THAT
THE SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY
COACHELLA VALLEY ARE COMPRISED
OF STRONG RESILIENT LEADERS
WITH THE PASSION OF IMPROVING
THEIR COMMUNITY. TO THE
ORGANIZATION THAT THE FOUNDED
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABLE. THROUGH
AND ACCOUNTABILITY LAST YEAR I
PARTNER WITH CHRONIC AND PHOEBE
TO CRAFT AND PASSED SB THREE
FIVE ONE TO EXPAND THE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM TO INCLUDE
RURAL UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES. A MAJOR VICTORY
FOR THE SOUTHERN VALLEY. AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL CHRONIC AND PHOEBE
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
HELPING LOCAL LEADER SECURE
NEARLY THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN TCC PROGRAM FUNDS FOR WEST
FRESNO. ONE OF THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGED
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE STATE AND
IN MY SENATE-DISTRICT. I WANT
TO THANK THEM FOR DEMONSTRATING
SO WELL HOW TO ENGAGE DIVERSE
CALIFORNIANS DIRECTLY AN
AUTHENTICALLY IN THE POLICY
MAKING PROCESS MEMBERS PLEASE
HELP ME SHOW OUR APPRECIATION
AND RESPECT FOR THE SINCE
NINETEEN. FOR ANNIKA DAY BYE IN
FEET SETON.
BIG CONGRADULATIONS.
RECOGNIZING SENATOR WESSEL AT
THE PRO TEM'S DESK. FOUR THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SEND
SENATORS IT'S MY HONOR TO
INTRODUCE JENNIFER GILMORE WHO
LEADS KITCHENS FOR GOOD IN SAN
DIEGO MISS KILMER'S TACKLING
HUNGER AND POVERTY BY BRINGING
TOGETHER TWO OF OUR REGION'S
MOST OVERLOOKED RESOURCES FOOD
THAT WOULD USUALLY GO TO WASTE
AN INDIVIDUAL'S LABELED AS
UNEMPLOYABLE. NEARLY ONE IN
SEVEN SAN DIEGANS STRUGGLE WITH
KEEPING FOOD ON THE TABLE
MEANWHILE UP 240% OF FOOD GOES
TO WASTE TO BRIDGE THIS GAP AND
TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF
SKILLED LABOR. IN THE CULINARY
AND HOSPITALITY HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRIES. UP MISS GILMORE
CREATED A CULINARY
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WHERE
PEOPLE WOULD SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT-
TRAINING THE TRAIN FOR CAREERS
IN THE CULINARY AND HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRIES BY PREPARING MERE
MEALS FOR KIDS AND HOMEBOUND
SENIORS IN SAN DIEGO. LAST YEAR
USING SURPLUS PRODUCE FROM
FARMERS MARKETS AND
WHOLESALERS- KITCHENS FOR GOOD
STUDENTS CHEFS AND VOLUNTEERS
PREPARED NEARLY A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MEALS FOR
APPROXIMATELY FOUR THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED CHILDREN SENIORS AND
FAMILIES AND END YOU A COUNTY.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT KITCHEN FOR
GOOD HAS BECOME THE GO TO
SOURCE FOR CULINARY TALENTS IN
IN THE SAN DIEGO REGION. UNDER
MISS GILMORE'S LEADERSHIP THE
ORGANIZATION HELPED HUNDREDS OF
INDIVIDUALS GAIN EMPLOYMENT.
MORE OVER 86% OF KITCHENS FOR
GOOD GRADUATES HAVE REMAINED
EMPLOYED AND RECEIVED A REYES
AND PROMOTION EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AFTER GRADUATION. MS GO MERCED
EXPLAINS HOW MANY FOR THE WORK
IS FOR HER STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITY WHEN SHE SAYS. THE
ONLY THING ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
AVE IN COMMON IS A LOVE FOR
COOKIE. THIS LOVE MAY SAVE THEM
FROM BEING IN THE KITCHEN WITH
THEIR GRANDMOTHER OR BE IN THE
BEST COOK IN THEIR SOBER LIVING
FACILITY EITHER ONE. FOOD
BRINGS PEOPLE TO THE TABLE
NOURISHES COMMUNITIES AND
TRANSFORMS LIVES. FOR HER
COMMITMENT TO UP LIFTING PEOPLE
WITH SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT AND SUPPORT FOR
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED BY
POVERTY AND HUNGER. I ASK YOU
TO JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
THIS REMARKABLE LEADER FROM SAN
DIEGO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THANKING HER SERVICE TO OUR
STATE.
THE BIG SENATE
CONGRADULATIONS I NOW LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR WIENER AT
CENTER HERTZBERG YES. I THINK
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OUR
COLLEAGUES. OUR NEXT TORTOISE
RECIPIENT IS- MARGARET LIBBY-
IS WHO IS TAKING BOLD PROACTIVE
STEPS TO GIVE YOU THE KNOWLEDGE
AND ACCESS TO BILL WELL FOR
THEMSELVES AND FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA EARNING THEIR
FIRST PAYCHECKS LIVE IN WHAT WE
CALL FINANCIAL DESERT. WHERE A
LACK OF ACCESS TO FINANCIAL
TOOLS EDUCATION AND QUALITY
BANKING INSTITUTIONS HINDERS
THEIR ABILITY TO BUILD CREDIT
AND SAVE ENOUGH MONEY FOR THEIR
FUTURE. AS A RESULT TOO MANY
YOUNG WORKERS LOSE THEIR INCOME
TO CHECK CASHIERS WHO CHARGE
EXPENSIVE FEES- IT MAKE IT
HARDER TO BUILD WEALTH AND
BREAK THE CYCLE OF POVERTY.
THAT'S WHY MARGARET FOUND IN MY
PATH TO PROVIDE YOUTH FROM LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WITH THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO ACHIEVE
FINANCIAL STABILITY. HIS LUNCH
A NUMBER OF INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
LIKE THE FIRST MODEL IN THE
NATION TO INTEGRATE BANKING AND
TO YOUTH EMPLOYMENT PROGRAMS AT
THIS PIVOTAL MOMENT IN A YOUNG
PERSON'S LIFE MARGARET AND HER
TEAM- HELP USED TO OPEN BANK
ACCOUNTS THE STEP BY UNTIL
GOALS. PRACTICE SAVING AND TO
ESTABLISH FINANCIAL DECISION
MAKING PRACTICES THAT WILL LAST
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFE.
ADDITIONALLY MARGARET
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU DEVELOP A
SET OF NINE STANDARDS OF
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
POLICY MAKERS CAN ADOPT. TO
REDUCE BARRIERS TO BANKING FOR
YOU. THESE INNOVATIVE STANDARDS
ARE ESPECIALLY CRITICAL FOR
FOSTER YOU AND IMMIGRANTS. IS
HEREBY PATH HELPS SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED YOU. CISCO AWAY SAN
DIEGO STOCKTON AND OTHER CITIES
TO EMBARK ON THE PATH TOWARDS
FINANCIAL STABILITY. 96% OF
PARTICIPATING YOU MEET THEIR
SAVINGS GOALS AND MANY
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THEIR
CREDIT SCORES. THE COLLEAGUES
TODAY I URGE YOU TO HELP I JOIN
WITH ME IN CONGRATULATING
MARGARET LIBBY FOR HER
GROUNDBREAKING WORK- TO HELP
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ACHIEVE ECONOMIC
MOBILITY. AND FINANCIAL
STABILITY.
CONGRADULATIONS TO
MARGARET LET LET ME FOR HER
HARD WORK SENATOR MINING AT
THAT PRO TEM'S DESK. MEMBERS
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
JACOB MARTINEZ FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF DIGITAL
NEST THROUGH HIS EXPERIENCE IN
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION. JACOBS
SAW HOW RURAL LET NEXT
COMMUNITIES BLACK TO BASIC
ACCESS TO WIFI WERE BEING
EXCLUDED FROM COMPETITIVE JOBS.
IN PUSHED OUT OF THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS TO ADDRESS THIS
JACOB LUNCH TO DIGITAL EST THE
PROGRAM PROVIDES TECHNOLOGY
ACCESS CAREER EXPLORATION IN
PAID ON THE JOB TRAINING TO
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND TEENS
AND YOUNG ADULTS. FROM WORKING
CLASS FAMILIES MOSTLY IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES IN WATSONVILLE AND
SALINAS JACOB ALSO PREPARE
STUDENTS FOR THE TECHNOLOGY
WORK FORCE YOUR CAREER
DEVELOPMENT AND ON THE JOB
TRAINING PROGRAM BUSINESS.
STUDENTS BUSINESS TO PROVIDE
GRAPHIC DESIGN WEB DESIGN VIDEO
AND PHOTOGRAPHY SERVICES TO
LOCAL BUSINESSES IN GAME FIVE
OH EIGHT WORK EXPERIENCE.
GRADUATES OF BUSINESS ARE
PLACED IN LOCAL JOBS IN
INCREASED ANNUAL INCOMES BY AN
AVERAGE OF TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. BOTH OF THESE PROJECTS
HELP RURAL STUDENTS REIMAGINE
WHAT IS POSSIBLE FOR THEIR
FUTURES I ASKS THAT YOU JOIN ME
IN RECORD I SING JACOB MARK IN
THIS IS. IN THE HEARING AND I'M
SORRY WORK. BIG SENATE THANK
YOU TO JACOB MARTINEZ- FOR HIS
WORK. RECOGNIZING SENATOR
SKINNER AT CENTER HERTZBERG
BEST THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THE
FANTASTIC SENATE DISTRICT NINE
HAS TO HONOREES AND LET ME
INTRODUCE THE FIRST ONE. HE
QUIETLY THE FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF ON COMMON LAW IS
TRANSFORMING THE PAROLE PROCESS
THROUGH HEALING AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. MANY OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SERVING IN OUR
PRISONS EXPERIENCED SEVERE
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA WHETHER
PHYSICAL SEXUAL OR EMOTIONAL
ABUSE AND LACKED THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVELOP THE
CAPACITY TO TRANSFORM THEIR
HAT. HARMFUL BEHAVIORS IN TO
HELP THE ONES. DRIVEN BY IS
BELIEVE THE PEOPLE DESERVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM THEIR
OWN TRAUMA WHILE TAKING
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS HE FOUNDED ON COMMON
LAW ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE
INCARCERATED FOR SERIOUS AND
VIOLENT CRIMES HIS ORGANIZATION
WORKS PRIMARILY WITH THOSE WHO
SERVE LIFE SENTENCES. UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP ON COMMON LAWS
ATTORNEYS THERAPISTS AND STAFF
SPEND MONTHS EVEN YEARS HELPING
THEIR CLIENTS UNDERSTAND AND
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF THE
DRAMATIC EVENTS IN THEIR LIVES
AND HOW DOES RELATE TO THE
CRIMES THAT THEY COMMITTED.
HELPING THOSE CLIENTS.
TRANSFORM AND ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE ACCOUNTABILITY
REMORSE AND PERSONAL
TRANSFORMATION DURING A PAROLE
HEARING. NOW OUR RATE OF PAROLE
OF YOUR GETTING A YES FROM A
PAROLE BOARD IS ONLY 18% AFTER
THE WORK WITH HIS AFTER COUPON
COMMON LAW WORKS WITH THOSE
PEOPLE SERVING LIFE SENTENCES
THEY HAVE ACHIEVED AN 80%
PAROLE RATEAND OF THOSE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN PAROLED WHICH IS
NOW OVER TWO HUNDRED AND 5099%
OF THEM THIS IS GOING BACK TO
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX HAVE NEVER
RETURNED TO PRISON. NEVER RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE SERVING LIFE
SENTENCES WITH THE POSSIBILITY
PRO IN CALIFORNIA IMAGINE. THE
AMAZING WORK THAT AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE ON COMMON LAW
COULD DO WITH THOSE FOLKS TO
MAKE NOT ONLY THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHOLE BUT OUR COMMUNITIES. MORE
AT SAFE AND STRONG. THEY'RE
FILLING A CRITICAL GAP IN
RETURNING HOLDEN HEALED PEOPLE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
KEEP WATLEY'S COULD WORK.
THANK
YOU TO KEEP WIDELY FOR YOUR
HARD WORK. I BY THE ORGAN IT
THE SECOND ARTERY FROM
DISTRICTNINE IS NEAR YOUR TO
TINY. THE
FOUNDER OF NOT FOUNDER SORRY
BUT THE EXECUTIVE CURRENT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ASIA
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK
IS AN OAKLAND BASED
ORGANIZATION. STARTING AS A
YOUTH ORGANIZER MERE YOSHI TINY
FOR MORE THAN TWO DECADES HAS
DEVELOPED AND MOBILIZED
GRASSROOTS LEADERS AT A PEN. A
PEN WORKS WITH BAY AREA ASIAN
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES TO
BECOME POWERFUL COMMUNITY
LEADERS TOGETHER THEY ARE.
BASICALLY BUILDING AND CREATED
A MOVEMENT TO SHIFT AWAY FROM
RELIANCE ON HAZARDOUS FOSSIL
FUELS AND OTHER POLLUTING-
ACTIVITIES TOWARD THE GREEN
ECONOMY THE BENEFITS EVERYONE.
EIGHT TEN AS ONE CAMPAIGNS TO
LIMIT REFINERY POLLUTION AN
INCREASE THE SAFETY OF
NEIGHBORHOODS ADJOINING THOSE
REFINERIES IN COMMUNITIES LIKE
RICHMOND THEY'VE ALSO WORKED IN
OAKLAND AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
TO ACHIEVE SEVERAL HOUSING
VICTORIES. AND PROTECTING THE
SECURE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR SENIORS AND OTHERS.
UNDER YOUR SHOULD TONY'S
LEADERSHIP A PEN RUNS ONE OF
THE LARGEST MULTI LINGUAL ASIAN
AMERICAN VOTER MOBILIZATION
PROGRAMS IN THE NATION.
ENGAGING VOTERS IN SEVEN
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES. NOW MOST
OF US MAY NOT REALIZE THAT
ASIAN AMERICANS ARE THE FASTEST
GROWING POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA YET THEY REMAIN
UNDER REPRESENTED IN OUR
ELECTRIC. MIA YOSHI TINY IN A
PEN ARE CHANGING THAT THEY'VE
GROWN A BASE OF OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND ASIAN IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES WHO SUPPORT POLICIES
AND BASICALLY. THAT KATE FOR
POLICIES THAT IMPROVE LIVING
WORKING AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING ME A YOUR SHOULD
TINY AND ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK.
CONGRADULATIONS TO MISS YOUR HE
TINY. I THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A PHOTOGRAPH OF THE ENTIRE
GROUP BACK HERE SO WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE COLLEAGUES WE WILL
DO THAT NOW.
I INVITE THE
MEMBERS TO JOIN THE AUTHORITIES
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE IN
THE PICTURE.
BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTIFUL. CONGRATULATIONS TO
ALL THE WARRANTIES. YEAH.
SENATOR MITCHELL YOUR RECOGNIZE
THAT THE PRO TEM'S DESK. I.
NINE FOR PURPOSES OF
RECOGNITION MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO
COMMEMORATE RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS AND HE'D MISS.
APPALLED TEMPER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY ARE YOU ALL
OF HEARD ME OVER THE YEARS TALK
ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE AS A TEAM
MEMBER WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
AND- YOU CAN PROBABLY BLAME
THEM FOR THE KIND OF POLICY
MAKER I GREW TO BECOME SO IT'S-
THEIR FAULT NOT MINE PAUL LIKE
MYSELF AS A NATIVE ANGELINO AND
IS DEDICATED MORE THAN FOUR
DECADES OF HIS CAREER. TO THE
NONPROFIT SOCIAL JUSTICE SECTOR
HE BEGAN HIS CAREER IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE AS A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR
SURVIVAL A GRASSROOTS ORGANIZER
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
STOPPING NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND
NUCLEAR POWER. LATER SERVED AS
LEGAL DIRECTOR OF PEACE AND
ESSENTIAL ORGANIZER OF THE
GRAVE IN PEACE MARCH. ALL
FOUNDED AND LED THE INSTITUTE
FOR THE STUDY OF HOMELESSNESS
AND POVERTY AND LA BASED POLICY
RESEARCH ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO BRIDGING THE RESEARCH GAP
BETWEEN ACADEMICS AND COMMUNITY
GROUPS WORKING TO FIND
SOLUTIONS THE PARTY LIVING
ALLEVIATION. HOMELESSNESS AND
INCOME INEQUALITY. AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE WESTERN CENTER
POLICY WORK DILIGENTLY TO
ADVANCE ITS MISSION TO FIGHTING
COURTS CITIES COUNTIES AND THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO SECURE
HOUSING HEALTH CARE AND A
STRONG SAFETY NET FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IN ADDITION TO
HIS WORK WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER POLISH SHARED HIS
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE AS A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA BAR FOUNDATION CHAIR
OF THE STATE BAR CALIFORNIA'S
LEGAL SERVICES PRESS ONE
COMMISSION AND AN ADJUNCT
FACULTY MEMBER AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AS A RESULT OF HIS
HARD WORK AND UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT POLICY COMPILED AN
IMPRESSIVE RECORD OF
PROFESSIONAL AND CIVIC
ACHIEVEMENTS THAT EARNED HIM
THE ADMIRATION AND RESPECT. ALL
ALSO CITY WITH. AND HIS BODY OF
WORK. AS HE RETIRES. INSERT SAD
FACE. HE LEADS YES THOSE THAT
FACE MEDICAL TERM HE LEAVES AN
INDELIBLE MARK OF EXCELLENCE AS
HIS LEGACY WEEKS IN DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR HIS DEDICATION
TO PROMOTING THE IDEALS OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT COLLEAGUES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ACKNOWLEDGING
THE WORK AND CAREER OF PAUL
TEMPER. SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
THAT. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SO I'D LIKE TO JOIN WITH MY
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES IN A KNOWLEDGE JEAN
PAUL WHO IS JOSH ONE OF THE
GREATS HE IS A MAN WHO EMBODIES
COMMITMENT. TWO IS BECAUSE SO
MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW SAYS OUR
CHAVEZ ONCE SAID BEING OF
SERVICE IS NOT ENOUGH. BEING OF
SERVICE IS NOT ENOUGH. YOU MUST
BECOME A SERVANT OF THE PEOPLE
AND WHEN YOU DO YOU CAN DEMAND
OF THEIR COMMITMENT IN RETURN.
I CAN THINK OF FEW INTO OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO I'VE KNOWN IN
MY LIFE. WHO EXEMPLIFY THE TRUE
NATURE OF PUBLIC SERVANT WHO
COMMANDS MORE RESPECT IN THE
FIELD OF SOCIAL JUSTICE AND IT
WAS LEFT TO GREAT FOOT PRINT
OURSOCIETY AND OUR OUR HEARTS
THAN PAUL. HE IS SPENT OVER
FORTY YEARS AS A CRUSADER. FOR
JUSTICE. GUARDING IN NINETEEN
NINE AS A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
AS SENATOR MITCHELL INDICATED.
FOR DECADES HE HAS BEEN AT THE
VANGUARD OF FINDING SOLUTIONS
TO POVERTY AND HOMELESSNESS AS
WAS SAID IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THIS NATION AND SINCE
TWO THOUSAND NINE HE IS GUIDED
THE WESTERN CENTER OF LAW AND
POVERTY ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AN IMPORTANT
ORGANIZATIONS OF THIS.
GENERATION TO LEAVE GREAT
VICTORIES FOR THOSE IT
REPRESENTS BUT PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANTLY MOST IMPORTANTLY
MEMBERS HERE'S A MAN THAT IS
GOOD AND DECENT AT HIS CORE.
PAUL WORKING WITH YOU AS MAY BE
PROUD TO CALL MYSELF A PUBLIC
SERVANT AND ECHOING THOSE WORDS
ASSESS OUR SHOP IS USER MAY
DEMAND MY COMMITMENT ANYTIME
CONGRADULATIONS I KNOW YOU TO
TAKE A DEEP BREATH BUT I KNOW
YOU WILL BE BACK. REGULATIONS.
MISTER TEPPER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK.
OKAY MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE TO
SENATOR NIELSEN ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY FOR SENATOR HL RICHARD
SEND AND WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
SENATE RULES WILL BE SUSPENDED
TO ALLOW LOBBYISTS ON THE FLOOR
SENATOR NIELSEN. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE WITH A
HEAVY HEART. WE WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU ONE OF OUR OWN.
SENATOR BILL RICHARDSON SERVE
TWENTY TWO YEARS IN THIS LARVAL
INSTITUTION. MANY CONTRIBUTED
MIGHTILY TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ONE OF THE
COLUMNIST WHO WROTE OF HIS
PASSING WROTE ABOUT THE MAN WHO
CHANGED THE CAPITAL. HE DID
BRING NEW DIMENSIONS TO THIS
INSTITUTION. WE HAVE SOME OF
HIS FAMILY HERE. WITH US TODAY.
THE BILL HAS WELL AS AN AD MAN.
HE ATTENDED UNIVERSITIES IN
WASHINGTON. THEN IT STARTED HIS
OWN FIRM. THERE WAS A PIONEER
IN DIRECT COMMUNICATION. WITH
THE VOTERS THE COMPANY HE
FOUNDED CALLED COMPUTER CAGING
WHILE HE WAS HERE WITH US
ADOPTING TECHNOLOGY. THE
POLITICAL MATTERS NOW IT IS
SOLD COMMON. AND SO WIDESPREAD.
BILL WAS ONE OF THE PIONEERS. A
TRUE GENTLEMAN. FEARLESS
FIGHTER. EVERYBODY DID NOT
AGREE. BUT THEY'LL- BUT
EVERYBODY RESPECTED HIS PASSION
AND HIS COMMITMENT. AND
PARTICULARLY. THAT COMMITMENT
TO THE INSTITUTION THE SENATE
THIS RULES ITS TRADITIONS. AND
SENATORIAL COURTESY. HE WAS THE
STEADIEST ABOUT THESE MATTERS.
I REMEMBER. WE HAD A BIG SENATE
PARTY ONE TIME TO THE- MANSION.
ELECTED THE YEAR I WAS WAS
SENATOR DIANE WATSON FROM LOS
ANGELES. NOW SENATOR WATSON AND
SENATOR RICHARD XIN WERE ABOUT
AS DIFFERENT POLITICALLY AS YOU
COULD EVER GET. BUT THE POINT
AT THAT EVENT. IT LIFTED ALL OF
OUR SPIRITS. WHEN BILL
RICHARDSON ASK DIANE WATSON TO
DANCE. AND HE WAS A MASTER
DANCER ACTUALLY HAD TAUGHT
DANCING OVER AND EVERYBODY
WATCHED ALMOST IN AWE IS THE
WALTZ ACROSS THE ROOM TO
POLITICAL OPPONENTS IF YOU WILL
BUT THE COLLEGIALITY. AND
COURTESY AND RESPECT THAT MARKS
THIS INSTITUTION. WAS
EXEMPLIFIED IN THOSE MOMENTS ON
THAT DANCE FLOOR. IN THAT
MANSION. BILL WORKED TIRELESSLY.
FOR THE SECOND AMENDMENT WHICH
HE BELIEVED IN. PASSIONATELY HE
FOUND THE GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEN GUN OWNERS
OF AMERICA. ORGANIZATIONS SHE
LED THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE. AND
THEY WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL
DEFENDING THE RIGHTS OF OUR
CITIZENS. THE BEAR ARMS. HE WAS
A STUDENT OF HISTORY. THE
HISTORY OF THIS BUILDING IN
THIS INSTITUTION AND OF ISSUES.
SOME OF HIS SPEECHES WERE KIND
OF LIKE A LECTURE ALMOST. YOU
CAN ALWAYS LEARN. FROM BILL
RICHARDSON. IT WAS A PASSIONATE
MAN. NEVER UP TIGHT. NEVER RUDE.
THE PASSION. THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE I THINK. HE HAD. WAS
A WRITER WROTE A COUPLE OF.
NOVELS WESTERN NOVELS. BUT
PROBABLY BETTER KNOWN FOR A
BOOK THAT IS MUCH TO MY DELIGHT.
TITLED SO WHAT MAKES YOU THINK
WE READ THE BILL'S. POKING FUN
THE INSTITUTIONAL LITTLE BIT
AND THEY WROTE ANOTHER ONE
CALLED CONFRONTATIONAL POLITICS.
NOW THAT TITLE MIGHT INTIMIDATE
YOU A LITTLE BIT. BUT I RATE
REDUCED IT TO ITS SIMPLEST
TERMS WHAT THAT MESSAGE WAS.
STAND UP FOR WHAT YOU BELIEVE
IN. STAND UP FOR IT
UNWAVERINGLY AND PASSIONATELY.
THE BILL RICHARDSON. DID THAT.
SERVING MANY YEARS HERE HE HAD.
MADE HIS MARK ON AN INSTITUTION.
THIS STILL WIDELY REMEMBERED.
AND WE GET TO HAVE A KNOWLEDGE
HIM AGAIN. THE DAY THE GERMAN
IS MEMORY AND I HAVE A LITTLE
MORE AND TO PRESENT TO THE
FAMILY THERE WAS A TECHNICAL
ERROR ON IT WE'RE CORRECTING
THAT SO YOU DON'T HAVE A
PARCHMENT IN HERE BUT WE WILL.
GET IT TO THE FAMILY. HE WAS
MARRIED TO HIS LOVELY WIFE
BARBARA. FOR FIFTY SEVEN YEARS.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW IT WAS FOR
BILL WHEN SHE PASSED IN THE
THEY HAD TO LIVE ON. BUT AFTER
ECONOMIC. MEAN TO MAYES TO LOSE
MARYLAND. THE BILL JUST TRUCK
DON AND CONTINUED HIS WORK. HIS
DAUGHTER LAURIE WORKED HERE FOR
MANY YEARS IN THE CAPITAL I
THINK OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR YEARS
IN THE CAPITAL HERE. DEDICATED
TO KEEPING THE RICHARDSON
FAMILY ON BOARD IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. HIS SON IN
LAW SAMPER RADISHES FAMILIAR TO
THIS INSTITUTION AS AN ADVOCATE
FOR THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HIS.
FATHER IN LAW FOUNDED. THEN
THANK YOU FOR THE PERMISSION
FOR HIM TO BE- MARXIST TODAY.
AS BILL. THE RECOGNIZED. HE HAS
ANOTHER A LOT OF OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY
MENTION DOT RICHARDSON IS SON
CANNOT BE HERE WITH US TODAY.
LAURIE IS HERE WITH US OF
COURSE AND SAM HER HUSBAND.
CHRISTY PARADE AS COLLINS JULIE
HORRENDOUS AND THEN WE PENSION
SAM ANNE HERBERT XIN HODGES
LISA HERBISON FORT BERMAN
BERBER. HENRY RICHARDSON AND A
SISTER JANE FASTING AND HER
HUSBAND TOM. AND WE HAVE WITH
ALSO HERE TODAY THE COULD NOT
DEACON BUT WE HAVE DELAYED. AND
THEY HAVE THEA GREAT GRAND
CHILDREN THIS BEAUTIFUL LADY
HERE I THINK WE'LL BE AMONGST
US SOME DAY FOLLOWING HER
GRANDDAD GREAT GRANDFATHER-
I'VE NOTICED- THE BEING VERY
PRECOCIOUS. THE THAT SEEMS TO
BE A FAMILY TRAIT WITH THE
RICHARD SINCE FOLKS BUT- AGAIN
I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
INTRODUCE THIS GOOD FAMILY. AND
FOR ME TO SING THE PRAISES OF A
GENTLEMAN SERVE NOBODY HERE IN
ADVANCE THE CAUSES HE BELIEVED
IN WITHIN THIS INSTITUTION. IN
GERMAN DOCTORS AT THE FAMILY
HERE. OF SENATOR BILL RICH OUR
FRIEND. SENATOR JONES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I JUST
WANTED TO ADD ON TO THE-
RECOGNITION OF US INTO
RICHARDSON AND I SHARE SOME
PERSONAL THOUGHTS- MYSELF. THE
BIBLE SAYS THAT IN A MULTITUDE
OF COUNSELLORS THERE IS SAFETY.
AND WHEN I ARRIVED HERE IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN I HAD NO IDEA WHAT
I HAD GOTTEN MYSELF INTO. A
RUNNING FOR THE STATE ASSEMBLY
IN AND ARRIVING INTO THE STATE
CAPITOL. AND ONE OF THE VERY
FIRST PEOPLE THAT- INSTITUTION
HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND ALL AND
A LONG TIME. A MENTOR TO LOTS
OF PEOPLE WAS H. O. RICHARDSON.
AND HAD THE HONOR OF WORKING
WITH HIS FAMILY- PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY AS WELL. AND
WHEN I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THEM- SOME LONG TIME FOLKS IN
MY DISTRICT SAID YOU GOT TO
MEET BILL RICHARDSON. I SAID
WELL. YEAH NO LIKE THE BILL
RICHARDSON I SAID YES AND THEY
ALL AND THEY WERE JUST AMAZED
THAT I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
MEET HIM AND SPEND SOME TIME
WITH HIM AND I READ HIS BOOKS-
WHICH REALLY- FOR ME HELP
SECURE- SOME OF THE-
CONSTITUTIONAL BELIEVES THAT I
HAD IT REALLY. DIDN'T KNOW HOW
TO SPEAK ABOUT THEM OR TALK
ABOUT THEM OR TEACH THEM AND HE
REALLY HELPED ME- THE ABLE TO
DO THAT. I THINK CENTER NIELSEN
DID A GREAT JOB OF SPEAKING OF
HIS LEGACY HERE IN THE CAPITAL
AND HIS SERVICE IN POLITICS BUT
ONE THING THAT I WANT TO SHARE
IS- WHAT HE TAUGHT ME IS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE LEGACY OF A OF
A- OF A PERSON A MAN OR A-
WOMAN. THAT'S THE LEGACY
THEY'RE LEAVING BEHIND IN. WHAT
ARE THEIR CHILDREN DOING. AND
OUT WHEN I LOOK AT BILL
RICHARDSON'S FAMILY AND SAW NOT
JUST HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS BUT
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF HIS
CHILDREN. AND THE LEGACY OF
SERVICE THAT HE POURED INTO HIS
GRAND CHILDREN. AND AS WE'RE
HEARING THIS MORNING HIS GREAT
GRAND CHILDREN. HE REALLY
CAUSED ME TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW
I WAS RAISING MY KIDS. AND WHEN
I WAS TEACHING THEM. AND THE-
WHAT I WANTED THEM TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT I WANTED MY
CHILDREN TO ACCOMPLISH. A
NUMBER ONE WAS TO HAVE A FAITH
IN CHRIST. AND THE BILL SEVENTY
HIS FAMILY AND I'M DOING MY
BEST TO BUILD THAT INTO MY
FAMILY. ANSWER AN ATTITUDE OF
SERVICE TO OUR COMMUNITY. WHICH
HE BUILT INTO HIS FAMILY. AND
I'M WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY THE
BUILDING TO MY FAMILY. AND SO I
JUST WANT TO SIT THANK THE
FAMILY FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING- AND FOR THE HEART AND
SOUL. AND CARE THE BILL
RICHARDSON HAD FOR THIS STATE
AND OUR COUNTRY WE'RE ALL HERE
TODAY. BETTER OFF BECAUSE THEY
TELL RICHARDSON WAS A STATE
SENATOR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME TO THE DESK SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT HE
IS PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED AND
ARE SENATE CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR. WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR FEBRUARY
EIGHTEENTH THROUGH THE TWENTY
AT TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING A BILLS SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
1-140-640-7408 491-150-5150 TWO
FIFTY THREE FIFTY FOUR AND
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE.
MEMBER GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
MOVING ON TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. ITEMS TWO AND
FOUR SENATOR WILK THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF LAN ON DRESS AS
CHIEF OF THE BUREAU SECURITY
AND INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES MISS
SUNDRESS WAS APPROVED POSTED
FEBRUARY TWELFTH YOU KNOW SPELL
IRIS. YOUR AYE VOTE. THERE IS
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI BATES
AYE BELL HI GORGEOUS HI
BRADFORD HI CAMBIADO HI JANE
HIGH DALLY BY DODD HI THERE
ALSO HI GALGIANI. HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ. BY WES SO HI- TADO HI
JACKSON I JONES HI LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI MONNING.
HI MORE LOCK HIGH MORALE.
NIELSEN BY PAN HI PORTANTINO HI
RALPH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN. HI BURKE BY Y. KO SKI I
WIENER HI WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROWS
MARIAH. ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS ADOPTED.
CONFIRMED SENATOR WELLS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I PRESENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF HAITI KEY
MIYAMOTO FOUGHT SLICE AND
ANDREW TRAN TO THE SEISMIC
SAFETY COMMISSION AND ROBERT
CARR JOANNE HAYES WHITE AN
OSCAR PRODUCT TO THE BOOK THE
PILOT COMMISSIONERS ALL THESE
APPOINTEES WERE PROVED APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY TWELFTH BUT THE FIVE
OH VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE. THERE IS FOR THERE IS OR
DEBATE. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BELL HI GORGEOUS. HI
BRADFORD HI A COUPLE YELLOW. HI
JANE HIGH DALLY I DONT HI THERE
ALSO HI GALGIANI. HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI GROVE HERTZBERG AYE
HILL HI WES SO. HI TADO HI
JACKSON HI JONES BY LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL I MONNING.
FIVE MORE LOCK HIGH MORALE. HI
NIELSEN I PAN. HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
HI NUMBER HI WHY CAO SKI HI
WIENER. HI WILL PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO SENATE THIRD READING ITEM
NUMBER NINE SENATOR DODD ARE
YOU PREPARED. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR DODD RELATIVE TO EATING
DISORDERS AWARENESS WEEK
SENATOR DODD THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MADAM PRESIDENT S. C. R. EIGHTY
THREE RECOGNIZE THE WEEK OF
FEBRUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TO MARCH FIRST TWO
THOUSAND WILL BE AS EATING
DISORDERS I WORK WEEK THE
UNITED STATES THIRTY IN
INDIVIDUALS SUFFER FROM
CLINICAL SIGNIFICANT EATING
DISORDERS SOMETIME IN THEIR
LIFE. THESE DISORDERS AFFECT
MEN AND WOMEN ACROSS ALL
BACKGROUNDS INCLUDED APRAXIA
BOSA BULIMIA NERVOSA AND BINGE
EATING DISORDER. ALL HAVE SEEN
FIRST HOW PAINFUL IT DIFFICULT
THESE DOT DISORDERS CAN BE.
I'VE HAD A LOVED ONE WHO
SUFFERED FROM AN EATING
DISORDER. I'VE ALSO SEEN THE
RECOVERY IS POSSIBLE AND I CAN
ATTEST TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
AWARENESS UNDERSTANDING AND A
STRONG SUPPORT NETWORK FOR
THOSE ON A JOURNEY TO RECOVERY.
NATIONAL EATING DISORDERS
AWARENESS WEEK IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BY THE
EATING DISORDER PROFESSIONALS
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS STUDENTS
EDUCATORS SOCIAL WORKERS IN
INDIVIDUALS. TO RAISE AWARENESS
OF THE DANGERS SURROUNDING
EATING DISORDERS IN A CRITICAL
NEED FOR EARLY INTERVENTION AND
TREATMENT ACCESS. THIS
pTHE CONVERSATION AROUND EATING
DISORDERS TO SHINE THE LIGHT ON
THESE DEADLY ILLNESSES DISPEL
DISINFORMATION AND TO RE CAN
CONNECT PEOPLE WITH THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED TO RECOVER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. PETER PAN.
I THANK MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS- I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THE SPORT RESOLUTION WHAT
THINK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM NAPA
FOR RAISING THIS- OFTENTIMES
WHEN PEOPLE THINK ABOUT EATING
DISORDERS- THEY MAY HAVE SOME.
RECOGNITION OF IT BUT I THINK
MANY PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
SERIOUS HOW PERSISTENT AND HOW
BADLY THEY ARE THE MORTALITY
RATE FROM ANOREXIA AND ROSA IS
EXTREMELY HIGH- BECAUSE AS THE
WELL BECAUSE THE EATING
DISORDER THIS IS ABOUT AS IN
THE BODY AND IT'S NOT ABOUT
BEING SICK AND IT ALSO BECOMES.
BASED BECAUSE THINGS LIKE THAT
AND OTHER OF CONDITIONS IT'S ME
IMPORTA THAT WE A SOCIETY
RECOGNIZE EATING DISORDERS AND
HELP GUIDE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THEM
TOO IT MEANT- AND THAT WE BE
SURE THAT WE COLLECTIVELY HERE-
BE SURE PEOPLE OF ACCESS THAT
TREAT WELL SO AGAIN THANK TRêN
FOR NOW BUT FOR. THIS AND SURE
THAT WE TRY TO RAISE AN S. THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE DISEASES
AND THAT- WE TAKE THEM
EXTREMELY SERIOUSLY. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NINE IT SENATORS
THIS ITEM IS IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NO OBJECTION EYES THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT OF COLLEAGUES THE
SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE A HEARING
COMMENCING AT TEN EIGHT AM
SHARP IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW TEN AM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR JACKSON'S.
IT'S THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SO I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU JOIN ME IN A CHURNING IN
THE MEMORY OF ONE OF THE GREAT
GREATEST GOLFERS HAVE PLAYED
THE GAME HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES. ONE OF THE GREATEST
GOLFERS MICKEY RIGHT. SHE WAS
ONE OF THE GREATEST ALL TIME
GOLFERS THIS COUNTRY. HAS EVER
HAD. SHE DIED THIS PAST WEEK
JUST HAVING REACHED HER EIGHTY
FIFTH BIRTHDAY OF A HEART
ATTACK. AND SHE WAS BORN IN SAN
DIEGO. SHE WAS BORN AND WENT TO
THE SAME HIGH SCHOOL AS THE
DOOR SAMUEL WILLIAMS OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS TED TEDDY BASEBALL. SO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT HIGH
SCHOOL CREATED TO THE GREATEST
SWINGS IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
SPORTS AND INDEED MAKING RIGHT
WAS KNOWN AND AGREED TO BY ALL
OF THE GREAT GOLF BREAKS. TO
HAVE HAD THE GREATEST SWING THE
GAME HAS EVER SEEN. SHE BEGAN
TO DEVELOP THIS PERFECT SWING
BY TAKING LESSONS FROM HER
FIRST TEACHER HARRY PRESSLER.
AND HER MOTHER DROVE HER A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILES EACH
WAY. TO AND FROM THOSE
PRACTICES THAT IS DEVOTION OF
MOTHER AS WELL AS DAUGHTER. AND
FOR MAKING A GOLF WAS NOT
EVERYTHING. BUT SHE- US THROUGH
IT AND AT THE YOUNG AGE WHEN
SHE WAS OFTEN TEASED AT SCHOOL
ABOUT BEING FIVE FEET EIGHT
INCHES TALL BY THE AGE OF
ELEVEN. SHE TOOK SOLACE IN
DEVELOPING HER SKILLS AS A
GREAT ATHLETE. AND SHE ARE IT
IS THE- RECORD OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT SHE WAS THE U.
S. GOLFING ASSOCIATION JUNIOR
KROLL CHAMPION AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTEEN IN NINETEEN FIFTY
TWO- SHIA. WENT TO STANFORD FOR
YEAR- IN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE
PLAYED ON THEIR GOLF TEAM
PROBABLY ONE OF THE FIRST WOMAN
EVER TO DO THAT I THEN DECIDED
TO TURN PROFESSIONAL AND BECAME
ONE OF THE GREAT SHE WON OVER
EIGHTY TWO. CHAMPIONSHIPS
SECOND ONLY IN THE WOMEN'S GOLF
TOUR- TO KATHY WHITWORTH WHO
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT. SHE WON
THIRTEEN MAJOR VICTORIES PUT
HER SECOND ALL TIME TO A
ANOTHER PATTY BIRDS FIFTEEN
MAJOR TITLES. NOT THE SAME
PATTY BERG WE- SHARED OUR
LEGISLATIVE EXPERIENCE WITH BUT
ACCORDING TO OUR PATTY BERG SHE
WAS NAMED FOR THE PATTY BERG
THE GREAT GOLFER- SO. OF MICKEY
WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY COMPANY
HER SUCCESS AT SO MANY OF THESE
EVENTS LED HER TO TOP THE LG
LPGA MONEY LIST FOR. ISN'T FROM
NINE SIXTY ONE TEN SIXTY FOUR.
AN EXTRAORDINARY RECORD SHE
DECIDED TO RETIRE THOUGH AT THE
RIPE OLD AGE OF THIRTY FIVE.
AND DID SO- AFTER BATTLING
CHRONIC WRIST AND FOOT INJURIES
TOWARD THE END OF HER CAREER
BUT NONE THE LESS. SHE
CONSIDERED AND I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING FOR THOSE GOLFERS WE
ARE E ARE REPUTED TO HAVE A
FEW IN OUR PRESENCE TODAY.
ISSUE WAS. A FIERCE IN HER
COMPETITIVE NATURE AND HER
TECHNIQUE AND SKILL BUT SHE IS
QUOTED AS HAVING SAID IN A
TWENTY TWELVE NEW YORK TIMES
INTERVIEW. THE QUOTE THE SECOND
GREATEST FEELING THE- IN THE
WORLD WAS A HIGH TO WIRE INTO A
WELL TRAPPED GREEN. WITH THE
ONLY BETTER FEELING BEING THAT
OF WINNING. THIS WAS A WOMAN OF
TREMENDOUS COMPETITIVE SPIRIT
TREMENDOUS SKILL SHE RETIRED AS
I MENTIONED AS A YOUNGER WOMAN.
THE VERY QUIET PRIVATE LIFE
THEREAFTER IN SPITE OF THE FACT
THAT SHE WAS SHOT AND IS TO THE
STATE THE ONLY WOMAN WITH A
DEDICATED ROOM IN THE U. S.
GOLF ASSOCIATION MUSEUM IN
LIBERTY CORNER NEW JERSEY. SHE
WAS ALSO ELECTED TO THE WORLD
GOLF HALL OF FAME IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX AND THE PGA HALL OF
FAME IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN SHE
THOUGH DID NOT ATTEND THESE
EVENTS BECAUSE OF HER VERY SHY
AND QUIET AND PRIVATE NATURE
NONE THE LESS DURING HER PERIOD
OF TIME WHEN SHE WAS NO LONGER
PLAYING ON THE GOLF CIRCUIT.
SHE BELIEVED IN PAYING IT
FORWARD TAKING INTEREST IN THE
CAREERS OF SOME OF THE YOUNGER
FEMALE GOLFERS ON THE NATIONAL
SCENE INCLUDING LUCY LEE WHO
REACH THE WOMEN'S OPEN AT THE
AGE OF ELEVEN. SO I WOULD ASK
YOU TO ENSURE NOT ONLY. IN
MEMORY OF A GREAT WOMAN GOLFER
BUT ONE OF THE GREAT GOLFERS OF
ALL TIME. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE BRING HER NAME TO THE
DEATH SO THAT SHE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO RETURN TO
PRIVILEGES AT THE FLOOR.
SENATOR PAN AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I RISE TODAY IS VICE
CHAIR THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS THE
TREMENDOUS HONOR TO WELCOME THE
SONS OF SECRETARY NORMAN MINETA
STEWART IN DAVID MINETA.
YESTERDAY FEBRUARY NINETEENTH
MARKED SEVENTY SEVENTH SEVENTH
ANNIVERSARY THE DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE A SIGNIFICANT DATE
FOR THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. BECAUSE ON FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH NINETEEN FORTY TWO
PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT SIGNED
EXECUTIVE ORDER NINETY SIXTY
SIX UNDER WHICH MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE. PEOPLE WHO ARE YOU MANY
M. USCITIZENS ONE CAR SERRATED
AND TEN DIFFERENT CAMPS
SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. NOW MORE THAN
EVER VERY CALIFORNIANS. EVERY
AMERICAN NEEDS REMEMBERED THE
UNJUST INCARCERATION OF OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
JAPANESE AMERICANS. THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICANS THAT SERVED IN
A PRESIDENTIAL CABINET
ECRETARY ME NORMAN MINETA WAS
IMPRISONED IN THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN INTERNMENT CAMPS
DURING WORLD WAR TWO. HE THEN
ROSE TO POLITICAL PROMINENCE
BECAME ONE THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
ASIAN AMERICANS IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR NATION. SACRAMENTO LED A
CONGRESSIONAL EFFORT FOR AN
APOLOGY FROM THE US GOVERNMENT
AND REDRESS FOR JAPANESE
AMERICANS WHO WERE IMPRISONED
DURING THE WAR. THAT EFFORT
FINALLY CAME TO FRUITION WHEN
THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW BY PRESIDENT
RONALD REAGAN. THE DAY IN
OBSERVANCE OF THE DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING SECRETARY NORM MINETA
SONS STEWART AND DAVE MINETA.
AND ALSO WE HAVE WITH US. SEVEN
INTERMENT CAMP SURVIVORS ERIN
YOUR CHEATER FROM THE CAMP TO
LAY LAKE CHRISTINE THE MEDIA
FROM CAP TO LAY LAKE IN HEART
MOUNTAIN. L. THE CALL M. JEROME
FIOS SATO WHO'S A CAMP PASTA IN
LESS A CITA THE CAMP TO ROME
GENET ANYWAY WAS AT CAMP TO A
LAKE AND ALAN KOREMATSU GRAND
NEPHEW OF FRED KOREMATSU PLEASE
WELCOME THEM TO OUR SENATE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY ON THE SENATE FLOOR THIS
DAY OF REMEMBRANCE.
THANK YOU
TO SENATOR PAN FOR THAT DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE RECOGNITION.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ACTIONS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. AND PRESIDENT
THANK YOU ALL IS GOOD AS WE AS
WE CONCLUDE JUST TO SAY HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND AND WE WILL. HAVE
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION MONDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY AT TWO PM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO
PM. THIS IS A FRIENDLY REMINDER
THAT THE LAST DAY TO INTRODUCE
BILLS IS TOMORROW AT FIVE PM.
THE LAST DAY TO INTRODUCE BILLS
IS TOMORROW AT FIVE PM. IN.